getting in front of the camera can seem
intimidating there's something that
happens when you hit that record button
it's the all eyes are on you
feeling and sometimes we can let the
fear of
failing actually hold us back for making
great videos
well in today's episode we are diving
into part two of
how to be comfortable on camera so we
can get past the fear
and start making great work my name is
heather torres and you are listening to
the think marketing podcast
we deliver a brand new episode for you
every single tuesday so if you're new to
the podcast
welcome make sure you're subscribed so
you don't miss an episode
and today's video is brought to you by
the free
side hustle challenge where you can
learn the 10 best ways to make money
online in 2021
you can get registered for free at idea
to income dot tips
that's idea to income dot tips not dot
com
if you want to sign up for the free side
hustle challenge
now we are going to dive into part two
of our two-part series
on how to get comfortable on camera
we're going to dive in the middle of the
interview
with sean cannell and brock johnson
where we're gonna go through
tips number five through eight now if
you missed last week's episode
definitely pause this one
go back and get tips one through four
because they're building on top of each
other
well i'm excited for this conversation
so let's jump right into the middle
number five is uh to make a gratitude
list
list why you're grateful and a lot of
these tips that i've been sharing and
this is very intentional
they are tangible they are things that
you can do they're not these big meta
terms some of them are but
a lot of these i want to give you steps
that you can walk away from
this podcast having learned and that you
can actually implement
so this is a great one that you can
tangibly do yourself and that is to make
a gratitude list it is scientifically
proven
that when you list the things you are
grateful for
first of all you're never going to be
able to end that list you could go on
for days and days and days i don't care
um what stage of life you're at or what
season you are in or what hardships or
triumphs you've recently experienced
there's an endless list of things that
you can be grateful for and it's
scientifically proven
when you write a list of things that you
are grateful for your mood improves
your confidence boosts all of that your
performance improves all those things
are
shown to improve by just practicing
gratitude so a great way that i like to
implement this into my own life is every
morning part of my morning routine is
making a list of things i'm grateful for
that day
brilliant and uh that's super powerful
what's number six number
six is similar to to number five which
was you know
make that list of gratitude but also
make a list of your strengths
make a list of your strengths but also
make a list of your weaknesses because
making a list of your strengths reminds
you of the things you can be confident
in the things you can rely upon the
things you know to be true
but also you can make a list of your
weaknesses
to remind yourself of these are areas
that i can improve these are areas that
like we talked about earlier you can
work on your confidence and you can
practice
but i think that really the list of the
strengths is a great place to start it's
a great jumping off point
and those are things that you can remind
yourself of and almost speak them as
affirmations
uh for yourself to remind yourself hey i
am good at some of these things you know
i do have these skills i have practice
um people like me for this people know
me for this these are my strengths
and you can build upon those to build
your own confidence
i love that and i'm sure though brock
you've encountered people that you help
that feel somewhat even blind to their
own strengths
and that can kind of get almost like
either kind of overly negative or just
they don't really see it because it
comes natural what what advice do you
have
if someone immediately goes i can't
think of any strengths
yeah yeah and that's a super super
common uh
response and i absolutely recognize that
and
here's what i would recommend reach out
to some of your close
friends i do say friends because
sometimes
family isn't necessarily by choice
friendship is usually by choice reach
out to some of your close friends
and just ask them like hey why are you
friends with me
why why why are you naturally drawn to
me and you know you can tell them hey
this is kind of a weird question this
might sound weird and i might be coming
out of nowhere but blame it on me say i
listen to some dude on a podcast and
he is making me ask you this question
but i'm wondering
what is it that you think is a strength
of mine what is something that
uh you feel drawn to me because of
and if you have good friends they will
give you some reasons back they will
respond to you with some some some of
your strengths some things you're great
at i wouldn't recommend doing this over
social media
but call your friends up send them a
text send them an email um
and and ask them why are they friends
with you why are they drawn to you what
strengths do they think
you have and heck if you wanted to you
could even lead it off by telling them
what some of their
strengths and some reasons you like them
are uh but i think
you know relying on those who love us is
a great way to remind us of why we
should love ourselves
yeah man your circle's so important and
what brock kind of
suggested and even worn there is you do
want to make sure that you don't get
into some kind of a toxic environment
when you're getting this feedback but if
you do have a good circle around you or
someone can speak into you someone knows
you and you know that's like a healthy
space
it could be one of the most powerful
things ever you know to bring up heather
taurus again
before she started her homeschool
channel back when we very first met
in the early days of pioneering video
ranking academy and she was kind of
the reason we linked up was because we
met on twitter
we found out that her and her family her
husband isaiah and their kids had moved
to las vegas
and she wanted to learn video she had a
particular set of skills
in digital marketing and ads and all
this other kind of stuff
course creation but was like afraid to
get on video
and when she started her homeschool
channel she was just like i have nothing
to talk about
i have no value to add to anybody i
don't know anything about this
i don't know what videos i would make
and those are the mindsets coming from
someone who had successfully now
homeschooled kids for six years who'd
probably read
38 books on homeschooling from all this
other stuff and i remember
we were just walking and i just gave her
a trigger question i said
what are the three mistakes that people
who just get started
uh make you with homeschool she goes oh
well and in response to the question it
just kind of naturally overflowed
that she knew all this information and
when it wasn't through the fearful lens
of oh shoot i gotta put this
on camera i gotta put this on a story i
gotta put this on a reel
when it was actually just kind of when
you're relaxed what kind of flows
naturally for you
it was a real strength but yet we can be
so
critical with ourselves or even kind of
the curse of knowledge so blind
to our own strength so i encourage you
get around people echoing brock
that could pull those things out of you
but also try not to be hard on yourself
because what do you research what have
you read about what do people
ask for your advice about what do people
look to you for what do people in your
family say
man you're great at that oh man when you
ever when you come to family gatherings
you're the one who brings the fire when
it comes to like cooking or
making healthy food or whatnot and
you're like i don't really know if i
could make a cooking channel about
healthy food on youtube of course you
can like everyone in your world
sees you for that everyone's asking you
for how to do accounting tips and
budgeting tips because you're just
you're great at it but you're like i
don't know if i'm as good as the people
don't count yourself out
and definitely tap the knowledge base
and the encouragement base
of your circle around you brock
we're on number seven uh what is it
yeah you you kind of said a word that is
a perfect segue
into it and you said you know when
you're relaxed and you're in that state
then it really just flows out of you
oftentimes we get this anxiety our blood
pressure rises our heartbeat's going
through the roof and we're
thinking about oh my gosh i have to go
live or i have to sit down and actually
record
this youtube video and that can be
really scary but i want to remind
everyone about how
powerful being in a meditative state can
be being in that relaxed what it's
called like oftentimes the flow state
or being in the zone is what's kind of
called in athletics
and it really goes back to this idea and
this would be the tangible way you can
practice it
visualization and meditation often times
like you talked about earlier sean
there's that confidence which is missing
so that we don't have confidence and
it can be a struggle just to build the
confidence it can be a struggle just to
start practicing and to put yourself out
there for the very first time
but a great way that you can do this is
through visualization
if you can visualize yourself doing
something your brain
doesn't necessarily know that you are
not doing it there have been so many
studies that have
proven this time and time again one
great one was they had
athletes they had pe students actually
so not even like basketball players
and they had one group practice shooting
free throws
a couple times a week they tested them
at the beginning of the week and they
tested them at the end of the week
then another group just visualized
shooting a perfect free throw it going
in
every single time for a week they tested
them at the beginning of the week and at
the end of the week
the group that just visualized did way
better
when they retested at the end of the
week they weren't even shooting a
basketball that whole week
now that's not to say that you should
never shoot a basketball if you're a
basketball player that's not to say if
you're a content creator you should
never create content
but it just goes to show you the power
of visualization and
the real tangible effects it can have on
your mind
so brock is there a routine that you go
through if you have say a live stream
coming up or of course you teach in like
your insta club hub community and
sometimes you got like a big training or
you speak on stages
do you how do you apply this yeah
absolutely so for me and this is
again another tangible way that you can
prepare um is
having an outline so for me i like to
outline the things that i want to talk
about
i also like to get an idea beforehand of
like what's the thing going to look like
if i'm speaking on stage
what's it going to look like when i'm on
stage if i'm doing a live stream
what is my you know what is my room
going to look like what's the ring light
situation what's my
my actual setup here in my home office
so i like to
in in a very real sense visualize and
see
everything that i would be seeing for
that event and
uh you know like i said earlier having
an outline so having just some notes
prepared
so i can hear myself speak and rehearse
and sometimes i'll even
record into my own phone kind of like an
audio recording of the things i want to
say
and then i can play that back to myself
and listen to myself speaking
which is kind of the next step to
visualization that's beautiful and as we
get ready for number eight
you know that actually kind of reminds
me i think we we just did a a
podcast episode if you missed it on our
youtube checklist and
getting the 10 steps of getting ready
for a video
including outlining it preparing even if
you want to get your lighting and your
gear dialed in and so definitely check
that out
uh in the archives if you missed that
episode um
but when i one of the most powerful
things i believe
for me and for us at think media is if
we can get our outline done ahead of
time and let it breathe a little bit
one of my favorite ways to let it
breathe is like okay i know i'm gonna
maybe do a live stream later
on a thursday and it's a wednesday and
my outline is done
i love to run and so i'll get up i'll do
a morning run
and i'm thinking about that at ten
o'clock it's eight
at ten o'clock i'm going to be going
live and there's
kind of a magic that happens there
because number one you're consuming all
of this oxygen your brain is fired up
there's all this blood flow
you're kind of getting that runner's
high and you're also in a state no phone
no distraction
you're just kind of out there and i've
noticed that in those moments too
it de-stresses you it's a way to uh of
course your your breathing all kinds of
physiological benefits are happening
and then i'm also thinking through i'm
kind of playing it out in my mind and so
um that's another kind of even just
tangible way where i found that that
almost adds like the outline is like the
kindling
and the the the wood for the fire and
then if you will the visualization and
the preparation in that moment
and that could also include things like
you know prayer uh yeah literally
closing your eyes and just playing it
out
going running but having a routine like
that can really then set on fire like
it's kind
of the thing to your point now you're
sinking through free throws
because you've thought ahead about it
and so that's another practical way and
i would encourage you
encourage you to of course find your own
uh routine right to find your own
because there's different people
these are these are proven science back
strategies that then of course you
incorporate into your own flow your own
style i know not everybody likes to run
some people like being in the gym
even go on a walk steve jobs was known
for loving to do walking meetings
because of the oxygen and the creativity
that would be sparked
but if one huge encouragement let your
outline breathe
it lets you i know what i like when i'm
finishing my notes for my slides
two seconds before i'm supposed to
present whatever it is or i'm under a
deadline and that is not helping me be
in a relaxed state
or a confident state i'm more in a
stressed and a rushed
state and if you can let it breathe
you'll show up so much
more powerfully on camera and for your
people brock number eight we made it
what's number eight absolutely so number
eight uh is preparation to prepare
and i don't know who this quote was for
some reason i feel like it's attributed
to abe lincoln but
um you know who knows where some of
these quotes come from but it's
basically
uh if you give me eight hours to chop
down a tree i'll spend the first six
sharpening the blade it just goes back
to that idea of preparation
i was a college football player we spend
months an entire offseason about nine
months preparing for a three-month
season
and within that three-month season we
spend six days
preparing for about a two-hour period
and really a lot of those times
those six six day periods they actually
started
preparing months in advance so sometimes
it's weeks if not months of preparation
for what comes down to a two-hour period
and then guess what within that two-hour
period
we're not on the field playing the
entire two hours you might get a total
of 35
minutes of on the field time so if you
add it all up
the preparation far outweighs the actual
execution and so what does this look
like tangibly
on social media or when you are a
content creator
it's first and foremost fully
understanding how to utilize
the different features and functions and
fundamentals of the platform that you're
on
if you're going live on tick tock you
need to know what all the buttons do you
need to know
how can somebody comment how can
somebody follow you if you are uploading
your very first ever youtube video
you need to know all of the different
aspects and what goes into creating a
good video and what goes into
the actual recording of that video like
how do you use your camera
so all of that first and foremost that
starts with your preparation
and your preparation can lead to
confidence so not only is it
the outline and making sure you're in
the right head space and all the things
that we've talked about
already but it's also preparing so that
you
you know you're ready for whatever is
going to be thrown at you and that you
really have
a full understanding and grasp of how to
use the platforms that you're using
and how to achieve the best results
brock
i am so fired up by that illustration
and our theme
this year at our company is wisdom based
off ecclesiastes 10 10
which is using a doll axe requires great
strength
so sharpen the blade that's the value of
wisdom it helps you succeed and i feel
like
abe lincoln at least if it was he who
said that quote
that basically was him saying that like
man if i'm going to cut down a tree
and i got a doll axe that's going to
take a ton of strength
but if i sharpen the axe first even for
six hours those last two are going to be
that much more
effective i just want to acknowledge you
think marketing podcast for actually
being here in this very moment
and sharpening the blade for being
someone that's committed to your
learning
to being someone who's committed to
leveling up for being someone
who's committed to do the practice do
the repetitions post the videos
to dial in your why to
focus on strengthening your strengths
and acknowledging your weaknesses to
being great
gratitude to having gratitude um to
working
on visualization and to mastering your
craft i just want to remind you and i'm
so grateful for everything that brock
has shared
that you have a mission you have people
you are called to
you have a purpose and people need you
people need you to show up right now
especially at this time in the world
where there's so much negativity and
vitriol
and controversy and division um we are
so passionate here at think media to see
you sharing your message boldly getting
out of your comfort zone
helping people solve problems helping
people reach
their ambitions entertaining people
educating people
and putting out world-class content
during the greatest
revolution that we've really ever seen
you know brock
as we land the plane uh there's a signal
fire article that said that the creator
economy tick tock creators instagram
youtube creators there's 50 million
some are amateur 2 million are
professional meaning they're earning
over six figures
and so many people are rising up from
the amateur turning this into full-time
businesses and that's part of our
mission here
and they declared this this is the
fastest
growing small business type um that is
happening right now that the creator
economy and of course i mean
tick tock game streamers but people with
youtube channels that are selling things
on etsy shops
entrepreneurs that are bolting on
youtube as a way to drive traffic to
their product services and consulting
and coaching
authors who are leveraging content
creation
so many different business models so
many different opportunities the fastest
growing
small business type and only accelerated
by a pandemic and by 2020
because more people are trying to figure
out how to work from home work online
and really build a life in business on
their own terms
cast a little vision as we land the
plane of what you
think this year what the opportunity is
what you see as someone who's not only
been in this for four years
but has been really a gen z perspective
on the state
of social media the internet and the
opportunity
in front of us right now what is the
future you see yeah
absolutely so the future is absolutely
huge
it's powerful and i think it's really
really exciting i think that i can speak
personally about instagram because
that is my expertise something that
happened in 2020 and was really
accelerated in 2020 by the pandemic and
and everything that happened is this
turning away and
i mentioned it earlier but this turning
away from the from the perfect
from the photoshopped from the super
polished
from the professional even and a real
turning to
what's real and i like to ask my
students you know
uh that they should ask themselves not
what can my followers do for me
but what can you do for your followers
what can i do
for my followers that's a question i'm
constantly asking myself and it keeps me
in this position
of servitude and i have seen it time and
time and time again so many
entrepreneurs and so many content
creators
are winning they're growing they're
building an income they're building a
business on social media
not because they're the prettiest person
you've ever seen or they have the most
amazing voice or they're the best dancer
or they have the
the greatest content that looks better
than anyone else's but just that they
show up
consistently and they serve their
audience and they
pour into their audience and they give
and they give to their audience
and because of that they are successful
and they grow i've seen it time and time
again on instagram
i'm seeing it on tiktok i see it on
pretty much every social media platform
and i think that should be really
encouraging for all of us
moving into the future is that this past
stigma that has existed around
social media and especially around
instagram that you have to have the
right filters
and you have to be the prettiest looking
and you have to make sure your makeup is
done and your hair is done you got to
make sure that
you look the best you have the new
clothes and all that but that
isn't necessarily true anymore and
what's true and what does matter most
is how much you serve your audience and
how much you pour into them
wow brock really left on such a high
note there
really seeing the opportunity that's
available online
and i can't wait for the side hustle
challenge that brock johnson chalene
johnson and brett johnson
are going to be hosting this february so
if you're listening to this podcast
right now when it's being released then
you're going to want to make sure that
you go over
and sign up for the free side hustle
challenge that's at idea to income dot
tips
and i can't wait for it to start you
know they really dive into the best ways
to be making money
online right now in 2021 and they're
gonna teach you one business that you
can start
today so i'm excited for that challenge
and really
the tips that brock gave were so
inspiring thinking about the gratitude
list now
that's a practice that i personally
started about five years ago i thought
it was really cheesy at first i'm like
of course i'm grateful for my kids and
my husband
and you know air and all those things
kids husband air
yeah that's in that order right uh but
really
you know the gratitude when you center
yourself on gratitude you start to
move from the feeling of selfishness to
the feelings of service because you're
just so
grateful for the things that you've been
blessed with i also
very much believe in the visualization
that brock mentioned for me every time i
get on camera
i read through my script i think about
smiling on camera i think about
connecting with the
you know lens as if it's an eyeball i
really think through the things i'm
going to say
the cadence that i'm going to speak and
really ultimately what the entire video
is going to look like
at the end i think visualization
especially when you are brand new
to getting on camera can be such a
missing piece
to getting over the fear if you just
visualize yourself as someone who's
already been doing this for a while
it's gonna help you and you're gonna see
that come through on camera
and then finally preparation you know
think marketing
listener that heather torres is all
about preparation you know that i am the
productivity queen and i love anything
to do
with really owning your time and
preparation is
so important also giving things time to
breathe like sean said
is really vital when it comes to jumping
on camera and feeling confident and
comfortable to press
record and i hope that you've enjoyed
this two-part series all about
uh how to be confident on camera and let
me know in the comments or
uh wherever you're consuming this
content do you like this type of podcast
where we bring our industry expert
friends on
and you get to see inside their world a
little bit and get some tips
from people other than sean and heather
now if you enjoyed this podcast we would
love if you would go over to itunes and
rate and review this
this helps us be able to get the podcast
out to more purpose-driven entrepreneurs
just like you and
when you rate and review our podcast you
might just get a shout out
on the show and today's shout out goes
to josh helm
he says love it appreciate what you all
are doing
i've tuned in numerous times and love
your style of teaching and influence
much thanks from the texas best
construction gang
josh we are so grateful for you for
being a part of our think community and
thank you so much for taking the time
out to write that review for us it means
the world to us to be able to
hear from the community on itunes so
thank you so much for that and if you've
not left your uh review
make sure you do that because you get
entered into a chance to win
a ticket to grow with video live 2021
well thank you so much for being a part
of our community here i hope that this
episode was something that encouraged
you to just
pick up the camera and press record
remember there's someone on the other
side of the lens
waiting for you to step outside of your
comfort zone you have a message
that your audience needs and all you
gotta do is just get over
the fear of pressing record thanks so
much for being here and we'll catch you
in the next episode
you